So check it out, here's your friend and somehow your friend got to go on a spaceship ride,
and they're moving at 60% the speed of light, and here you are down at earth
bored watching your friend, jealousing.
Now, since you guys know some special relativity, you guys agreed on an experiment.
So what your friend said he's going to do, he's going to hold a little stop watch
and every 8 seconds, he's going to wave at you--hello.
So you know that in his frame of reference every 8 seconds he's waving.
So I want to know in your frame of reference using your clock measuring t',
how long is the time interval between waves.
Remember, he's waving every 8 seconds.